In September of 2022, a video
began circulating online
of a man named Yevgeny
Prigozhin at a prison in Russia
speaking to inmates and offering them
the chance to fight in Ukraine.
Yevgeny Prigozhin was an acquaintance
of Vladimir Putin's from
St. Petersburg in the 1990s.
He's close to Vladimir Putin.
He actually got his start
focusing more on catering
businesses and restaurants,
earning himself the nickname Putin's chef.
In the beginning, he
stayed in the shadows.
He rarely appeared.
He was named by some Western officials
as being in charge of Wagner Group,
but the Kremlin kept it very hush hush.
They didn't want it to be known
that this group really existed,
they denied knowing anything about it.
Wagner is nothing like what
Americans might understand.
It's a private military company.
Wagner are mercenaries for hire.
They massacre and rape civilians,
they exploit, loot natural
resources, and they carry it off,
much of this back to the Kremlin.
The significance of this video
is it immediately ties
Prigozhin to the Wagner Group.
He'd always denied any involvement
but here you have him on camera
describing Wagner as his group
and describing what they're doing.
It was a way of planting
the flag and saying,
"I'm in charge here.
I've got permission to
do whatever I'd like."
That is in fact the function
of the coming out story,
to convince us that that is the only story
that there is to know.
This is a business story
at the end of the day.
This is a story about the exchange
of billions and billions of dollars
for large scale weapon platforms,
for train and equip missions,
for oil and gas exploitation.
What we're really seeing here
is a very strange organization
that doesn't look at all
like your classic
private military company.
In fact, it's probably better to call it
a state-backed paramilitary cartel.
Are you a Russian soldier?
The shadowy pro-Russian forces here
violently took over government facilities.
The Russian mercenaries were from the-
Wagner Group.
The Wagner Group.
The Wagner Group,
a shadowy security firm
linked to Yevgeny Prigozhin.
The tentacles of Wagner
spread across Africa,
Syria, and Ukraine.
They relish in their brutality.
Nothing could be more appropriate
than designating it as a
foreign terrorist organization.
Could someone like Prigozhin
ever actually threaten
Vladimir Putin's hold on power?
It's absolutely unclear how this will end.
In the 10 years since its founding,
the Wagner Group has evolved
from a small guns for higher operation
into a sprawling network of businesses
that has been active on four continents.
This is setting up a broader
network of infrastructure
where Wagner could
potentially surge presence
in response to a given
opportunity or threat
and also it creates the opportunity
to sort of lily pad their influence
from one country to another.
Wagner currently has approximately
50,000 personnel deployed to Ukraine,
including 10,000 contractors
and 40,000 convicts.
President Putin wants Russia
to be a great power again.
He wants it to have
control throughout not only
Europe and Asia, but also in Africa
and other parts of the world.
He's been able to send in his
mercenaries through Wagner
to do the dirty work.
The Wall Street Journal
examined shipping records,
government databases,
sanctions documents and corporate records
to identify 64 companies
linked to Wagner's founder,
Yevgeny Prigozhin.
We found more than half of
those are being used by Wagner
as a complex network of front companies
to hide the flow of money and materials
that ultimately connect to the Kremlin.
Neither the Kremlin nor Prigozhin
responded to requests for
comment about our findings.
The monies would flow
back through the corporate form
and they could be used to pay salaries,
they could be used to pay weaponry,
they could be used to pay for everything
that a military needs,
but not coming through the Russian state.
It's always gonna be a game
of whack-a-mole for the
US and other governments
because the more companies
that are sanctioned,
the more companies will be
created to evade sanctions.
Every part of what the Wagner Group does
is directed by the state for the state
to the profit of the state.
But from the beginning,
the Wagner Group was carefully engineered
to hide its connection to the Kremlin.
Ukrainian and Western officials
say that the way it was
done was Yevgeny Prigozhin
through his catering company, Concord,
was making money from
defense industry contracts
so he was getting
contracts to provide food
and other services for the Russian army,
which he was then able to
reinvest into the Wagner Group.
It is a classic money
laundering technique.
Concord Catering was what it sounds like.
It was set up as a catering company
that had sweetheart
deals with the Kremlin.
So the Kremlin would pay it
and it was the catering company.
And then as part of that,
there are ways to skim
that money off the top
and ensure that the money
goes to the appropriate folks
that Prigozhin wants to pay.
It was through parts of that money flow
that it's expected that
Wagner got its start.
The origin story of the Wagner Group
is basically a battlefield rumor.
At the beginning of the war in Donbas
and the annexation of Crimea in 2014,
we saw a lot of guys without insignia,
you know, the little
green men running around
and they were often talked
about as not being there.
The Kremlin always believed
that Ukraine should be part of Russia
and that naturally the
Ukrainians should support Russia
so it tried to foment a
revolution, some kind of uprising
in Eastern Ukraine.
Russia used small mercenary groups
to support pro-Russian separatists
in their fight against Ukrainian forces.
Now one of these groups was Wagner.
Because they offered plausible deniability
for the Russians, they could
say that these were locals
that had simply decided to rise up
against the rulers in Kyiv.
There are no Russian units
in the east of Ukraine, no
special services, no instructors.
Those are all local residents.
Dmitry Utkin was one of
the original commanders
in Wagner and in fact,
his call sign was Wagner
and that's what gave the unit its name.
Now he was known as Wagner
because of his neo-Nazi sympathies.
Russia's attempt to foment an uprising
in Donbas ultimately
faced stiff resistance
from the Ukrainian army.
And according to the Ukrainian
intelligence service,
the Kremlin used Utkin and his Wagner unit
to target pro-Russian separatists
who opposed negotiating
a ceasefire with Ukraine.
Essentially, they were a
death squad that was sent out
to clean up any of the political problems
that the Kremlin was dealing with
during this negotiation process.
The might of Wagner Group
rose from year to year
because they appear to be very effective
for this Russian authoritarian regime.
For Putin himself, he could hide
any kind of his criminal activities
using these kind of troops.
In 2015, Russia intervened
in the Syrian Civil
War and Wagner was used
to protect energy resources
for the Assad regime.
It was the beginning of a new
business model for the group.
And in return, they get a
share of the natural resources,
the looting of the country.
It was a pivotal role in a conflict
that put one of Russia's most
important allies at risk.
That meant Wagner and the Russian military
fought against any combination
of US-backed rebels,
Kurdish forces, and ISIS.
Wagner employed its fighters in Syria
through a company called Evro Polis.
Evro Polis was also the company
the Syrian government hired
to protect its oil fields.
Ultimately these shell companies
that are paying the salaries
of Wagner Group fighters,
they're nothing more than that.
They're just paper pass
throughs that allow Russia
to manage money and men
and make sure that there are
no prying eyes in the deals.
Oil was particularly lucrative
for Wagner in Syria.
Evro Polis's contract
with the Syrian government
shows that for every
oil field it captured,
it got 25% of production.
25% of the natural resources,
the energy resources
that were able to be exploited.
An incredible amount for a
company far afield in Russia.
By 2017, Wagner captured at least four
of the country's largest
oil and gas fields,
which earned the group
tens of millions of dollars
per year from each field.
Make sure that you secure the oil and gas,
get it before the Americans get it
or get it before the Kurds
get it, but get there.
That was the objective.
Al-Shaer gas field in Homs
is one of the largest in Syria.
In 2017, Wagner worked
with the Syrian military
to defend it from ISIS.
Many of the Syrian troops
had been forced into
service by the Assad regime.
During a Battle with ISIS,
some of those Syrian
fighters tried to escape.
Wagner found one of them
and decided to make an example of him.
His name was Muhammad Ismail.
Wagner fighters filmed themselves
as they tortured, killed, and
mutilated Muhammad Ismail.
We see kind of this impulse
toward memorializing
terrorizing incidents.
This helps with the kind
of psychological effects.
Don't mess with us.
We're coming and when
we come, be prepared.
In 2018, Wagner forces
attempted to capture
the Conoco gas plant in Kasham
from US-backed rebel forces.
There was already kind of a lot of tension
leading up to the Battle of Kasham,
and then when the Russian regular forces
couldn't give the Americans an answer,
a satisfactory answer
as to who was down there
doing that fighting creeping
toward the Conoco gas plant,
well, it was kind of all bets off.
The US military sent up a
whole bunch of air cover
and it was an absolute bombardment.
Even though Wagner lost the fight
for the Conoco gas plant,
they still served a
very important purpose,
taking heavy losses that the
Russian military couldn't.
You can't count what you can't see
and you can't count what you don't know.
One of my duties was to
actually fly on board
of transport aircrafts.
Russian military aircrafts
were filled with bodies
killed in action operators
from Wagner Group.
What I witnessed being at mission at Syria
as an Air Force officer
was this Wagner Group
used all the resources of
Russian official military.
They used their military aviation,
they used their logistic capabilities,
they used their military bases.
By 2019, the Syrian government
awarded several Wagner companies
oil and gas drilling rights
to about 10,000 square miles
of land across the country.
As recently as 2021, a Wagner company
was awarded oil and gas drilling rights
for 2000 square miles
of offshore territory.
Some would point to Syria
as a pretty successful model
of how business could be done.
They went in surreptitiously,
they managed to grab back a
lot of the important oil, gas,
and mineral resources for the
Syrian state and for Russia,
and they did that at minimal cost.
Russia's found itself
a very successful model
and it wanted to replicate it.
And the group did just that
as it expanded to Africa.
I'd say the biggest success
for the Wagner Group
that we know of now is in
the Central African Republic.
In Africa, Wagner set up
even more shell companies
to mine natural resources
and sell them around the world.
Wagner was able to do that
through offering security services.
Wagner targets countries
with ongoing security issues.
Some are former French colonies
with governments weakened
in the wake of reduced
French military presence.
In the Central African Republic,
Wagner uses a company called
Sewa Security Services
to provide security to the president
and other high level officials.
Sewa is a subsidiary of Lobaye Invest,
which has at least three
mining licenses in the country.
The first Wagner troops arrived
in the Central African
Republic in January of 2018
where they quickly got to work
carrying out training tasks
and setting up bases where
they could help to instruct
local armed forces.
Wagner quickly got to
work taking over mines.
One of the largest is a
roughly 138 square mile
swath of land known as the Ndassima mine.
It was a small scale mine where
everything was done by hand.
Wagner developed it
into the only industrialized
gold mine in the country.
I'm a lawyer for Axmin,
a company based in
Central African Republic.
We've been listed in Toronto Exchange.
Axmin was granted the Ndassima
mining license back in 2010.
Unfortunately, in 2013,
a civil war broke out
so obviously as a company,
we weren't able to go into exploration.
Rebel groups like the Union for Peace,
known as UPC, took control
of the Ndassima mine
for the next several years,
until Wagner forces took over around 2017.
In 2019, we received a
document from the government
saying that our permit was canceled.
Two months later, we received
information that in fact,
Midas, which in fact was run by Wagner,
it was awarded our license in Ndassima.
Midas Resources is a Wagner company
created for mining in the
Central African Republic.
The Journal was unable to find
any prior mining history for Midas.
In a 2011 report, Axmin projected Ndassima
could produce more than
1.4 million ounces of gold
over about eight years.
That's nearly $3 billion
worth at today's prices.
Today, the government
has no way of knowing
what's going on in the field
because it has become off
limit for the government
since Wagner took over.
Satellite imagery analyzed
by The Wall Street
Journal further confirms
Wagner's presence at the mine.
This December 2022 image shows
a Mi-8 or Mi-17 helicopter,
the same kind of choppers
Wagner uses elsewhere in Africa.
Here, a type of armored vehicle
military analysts call a Wagner wagon
is identifiable by its
roof mounted extra tire
and its pointed front end.
These customized combat trucks
were also used by Wagner
forces in Syria and Libya.
Satellite images show the expansion
and industrialization of the mine.
On the right, we can see heavy machinery.
We're able to actually see
some dump trucks and
diggers in the imagery
that have been expanding
these open pit mines.
On the left, we can see the expansion
of facilities and two processing lines.
Together, these developments
show the country's
first industrialized gold
mine built by Wagner.
We are not naive about the situation.
It's highly unlikely
that we will get it back.
As Wagner-linked companies
took control of mines,
its fighters killed anyone in their path.
One such incident occurred in
2021 in the village of Boyo,
about 100 miles south
of the Ndassima mine.
The Muslim community there was targeted
because Wagner forces and
their allies believed them
to be helping the UPC rebels,
who previously controlled the mine.
The Boyo massacre was documented
in a 2022 report to the
UN Human Rights Council,
which detailed the brutal
assault on civilians there.
The Boyo Massacre is one small example
of atrocities Wagner has
committed across the continent.
At the same time, Wagner-backed companies
continue to spring up across Africa
in different sectors of the economy,
particularly in the
Central African Republic.
An overall playbook is step one,
enter into a military technical
agreement with Country X,
Central African Republic, Mali.
You get the helicopters,
you get the guys who fly the helicopters.
You get the jet fighters,
you get the guys who
fly those jet fighters.
You get the infantry fighting vehicles,
you get the guys who drive them.
That's the playbook, but
then there's a second layer.
We see this narrative
of Russia coming in as
a friend and a helper
repeated in various types of
propaganda and disinformation,
ranging from Soviet art style billboards
in cities in the Central African Republic,
and even getting down to the level
of creating children's cartoons.
We will make sure that the story
that you're trying to
sell to your electorate
is the one that's sold on social media.
Officials, some people are just saddened
by what's happening in the country.
Things are getting worse and worse.
The country has become
a sort of rogue state
with the Wagner calling all the the shots
on behalf of the government.
U.S. and European security officials
told The Journal that Wagner
is also trying to expand
to Burkina Faso, Chad, and Ivory Coast.
Every weapon that goes
into Africa is money.
Every bit of gold that comes
out of Africa is money.
That money services a
lot of different needs.
It has been all along a
sanctions management strategy
insulating Russia from
what would inevitably come
if it ever crossed the line into Ukraine.
After backing Wagner
through its massive expansion in Africa,
Russia called the group back
for the urgent need of the state,
a full-scale war on Ukraine.
Wagner would soon outshine
the Russian military
on the battlefield.
It's expected that the money
that Wagner, Prigozhin,
and their front companies are
reaping throughout Africa,
hundreds of millions of dollars a year,
much of that is expected
to go back to Russia,
some into Prigozhin's pockets,
but much of it for the
war effort in Ukraine.
The initial invasion on February the 24th
was carried out by the Russian military.
They fired missiles,
they sent in war planes,
and then they sent in armored columns.
And they very much thought
that this was a war
that would last for a few days.
We know that there was money flowing
outward from the Kremlin to
Prigozhin and his companies.
We know that some of that money
was funneled in to Wagner.
The Wall Street Journal reviewed contracts
between the Russian
government and 25 companies
tied to Prigozhin, likely only
a small portion of the total.
Collectively, these
companies won more than
$5 billion in contracts
between 2014 and 2023
with a notable spike in the amount
in the year after the war began.
So a significant amount of
money for guns, for tanks,
for other weaponry that can be used,
that all needs to be funded somehow.
As Moscow's plan to take Kyiv failed,
Russian troops and Wagner
fighters were stuck in towns
on the outskirts of the city.
One example that we have
of how the Wagner Group
was active around Kyiv was
from the village of Motyzhyn.
According to prosecutors
and according to the Ukrainian soldiers,
Wagner Group was brought in
as an interrogation and torture team.
As the Litvynenkos ran
from the indiscriminate fire,
their daughter was shot.
Mykola pleaded with the
Russians to save her.
They were taken to a Russian
base at a nearby farmhouse.
As the conflict evolved,
Russia's needs for Wagner also evolved.
Russia put a lot more
focus on its operations
in the east of Ukraine.
Wagner Group became a
critical part of this.
Here you see them really
serving the purpose
of doing a couple of different things.
One, that frontline piece
but also they've obviously
been very important
for force mobilization.
Wagner began recruiting from prisons
to make up for large Russian
losses on the battlefield
and to avoid drafting more
civilians into the war.
This method was used in
World War II by Stalin.
Going into the prisons,
pulling people out,
putting them on the front line,
turning them into cannon fodder.
The move to recruit from prisons
signified a new phase for Wagner,
one in which the group stepped
firmly out of the shadows.
It represents the clearest evidence yet
of just how connected
Wagner's operations are
to the Kremlin.
The Wall Street Journal interviewed
convicts recruited by Wagner
and later captured by Ukrainian forces
who describe being
transported from their prisons
to the front lines in
Ukraine with state resources.
Social media videos gathered and verified
by The Journal show dozens of trucks
with federal prison markings
arriving at commercial airports
and military airfields across the country.
At the airport in Penza, Russia,
these trucks can be seen
driving onto the tarmac.
Men who appear to be prisoners
unload from the trucks
near several airplanes,
at least one of which is registered
to the Russian Air Force.
The fact that Prigozhin
can recruit in prisons
demonstrates the level of
power that he achieved.
I think you can likely expect to see
an expansion for Wagner
of its contracts and ties within Russia
so long as it's perceived
to be successful.
By May of 2023,
the man who started out 10
years ago as Putin's chef
was openly attacking
Russia's Ministry of Defense
and its top commander in Ukraine,
acts that would send most to prison.
We should expect the Wagner
Group to continually change
according to Russia's fortunes
when it comes to arms,
guns, gas, oil, and gold.
I think it's likely that in the future
you won't have any contracts
with the Wagner Group publicly
in any jurisdiction outside
of Russia or its close allies.
We may see a new name.
Could be anything, could
be Tchaikovsky Group.
We don't know.
At this point in time,
Wagner activity is confirmed
on at least four continents.
It's not only about Africa,
it's also about Latin America.
It's not just that Russia
is spreading its influence
in these countries,
but Russia is further destabilizing
some of the areas where global
security is at its weakest.
Democracy's at stake in
many of these countries.
But what's at stake is even
something more fundamental
for the people of those jurisdictions,
it's their very lives.